thank you again all of you for taking
the time from your very exciting week
here to uh to listen to me and I hope uh
I can share some insights with you but
before I dig into that I just wanted to
um return uh DJ's amazing introduction
uh as you know he's a very accomplished
man he's a man of Grace lot of
confidence and uh but you I want I want
you to know that below all this
composure there is a lot of fire burning
just like it did for all of you and me
when I first uh joined the school and um
and we know we all thought we were hot
we made it to the best business school
in the world world and uh one of the
things I learned was how to read The
Wall Street Journal so uh I picked up
yesterday's Wall Street Journal
and the business school ratings
recruiter recruit recruiters NBA picks
and uh talks about Something Old
Something New and I was really curious
whether I'll find my school here so I
started at the top it
[Applause]
says
University of
Michigan
Berkeley
Thunderbird Michigan State
University by the time I got to the
bottom of the list I was really happy I
went to State School
[Music]
undergrad but uh uh I thought that the
rec recruiter's view would be important
especially since you all are worried
probably about how you're going to pay
for all this uh great education where
you going to get and I got and uh so uh
I actually I wanted to share a little
bit more about what the article said and
which is amazing it talked about how the
recruiter's view
is the rankings aren't necessarily a
reflection of the schools with the most
C uh celebrated academic
reputation uh although the 21 attributes
include the curriculum and the faculty
academic quality isn't the primary
concern uh of most survey respondents in
state they care most about the NBA
students interpersonal and communication
skills we have plenty of opport for you
to learn all that with the LPF on
Fridays with the Tuesday nights with the
golf access and uh that help explain why
some of the most renowned schools such
as Harvard and Stanford don't rank as
highly as the survey as the other
schools blah blah blah and then it talks
about basically we're all arrogant here
and hard to deal with and uh the
recruiters don't like us so uh of course
I don't believe any of that and uh but
in case you're worried about the jobs I
we had an intern actually from uh from
your school in my class and he told me
I'm not worried about paying for the
school because I learned how to use
Google ad Wars which was our ad system
to actually create an Arbitrage site and
make money and he already paid
apparently for his school uh I was
talking to the Harvard alumni last night
and I learned that they load up on loans
they hook up with their Finance experts
and classmates and they figure out how
to Arbitrage so I don't recommend any of
this but these are some techniques you
may want to use to uh uh if you don't
end up with any jobs given what the
survey says
so I'll hurry you though so uh let's see
let me uh start all getting aside with
uh you know why I believe uh we're all
here and you are here and uh you know is
it a break from your career uh you
wanted to step back and really immerse
yourself in this amazing environment
with uh your great great classmates with
uh just incredible education institution
that you have here and the environment
uh is it really uh that you want to
become a CEO and you want to know how to
do that or become an entrepreneur or an
investment banker or Management
Consultant uh is it is it really to find
a partner in fact there's an amazing
story uh in the same Auditorium my dear
classmate and actually board colleague
at um a fellow board member at The
Advisory Board uh met uh her future
husband Steve Jobs and it happened in
this room my assistant it reminded me
I'm married so
uh probably that won't happen today
but um or is it really to challenge your
comfort zone and I think uh uh for me at
least it was really all of the plus one
one more really incredible quality I
cared about which was uh really this
openness uh to be surprised to really
get me out of this comfort zone uh to
really gain insights about myself and my
ambitions you know I thought again I was
pretty hot I was a engineer that made it
to HP and became a product marketing
person traveled the world had five years
of this incredible experience when HP
was very hot and uh and that uh you know
I got the only school I applied to I got
in thanks to Karen and uh uh and you
know I thought I I really just need a
little bit of polishing and business
experience and that's what uh the
business school is going to do for me
and what it has really done though is uh
this amazing portfolio of aha moments
you know when I look back at my
education and I look back at my
experience at Stanford this is what I
really recommend you guys focus on is
that uh it's not really the
specialization or the Deep dive in the
topics you're going to get you you
you're going to hear this from everyone
you're going to forget all that uh it's
uh it's it's really these incredible aha
moments and these experiences that you
have not just in the class could be be a
quote from a professor could be an
experience you have with your classmate
traveling uh on one of the incredible
projects that becomes available here A
bunch of my classmates went to see the
the Wall fall down it gives my age away
uh in Eastern Europe and uh it's it's it
is really those moments and my goal
today uh is really to share some of
those that were very personal for me
that not only shaped my experience at
Stanford but really helped me uh and
guided my career uh in a in a
significant way uh and let me let me
start by uh recalling some of these
classroom quotes and classroom moments
uh uh one of my favorite classes was a
leadership class by John Gardner who I
believe he passed away and uh he was the
president of carnegi Corporation if
you're not familiar with him he was the
education secretary in the JFK
Administration and uh he you know at the
time I was I was a extrovert person in
in kind of a business environment but I
I'm more of a person that really enjoys
deeper solid conversations with people
so more of an introvert in that sense
and I never thought of myself as a
leader and now half the company half of
of Google reports to me and uh one thing
he told me was that leadership can be
learned and that's the only thing I
remember from that class and uh and
today I did pass the course with good
grades but but today that's the only
thing I remember from that class and it
and it's incredible every time I remind
myself I'm going to do something really
tough or I'm going to take on a new
challenge I remember what he said that I
can learn this and and I really believe
that I never thought of myself uh being
comfortable speaking to this incredible
audience like I have today or thousands
of people at a conference or you know
mobile Iz my organization at Google the
way we have and uh it was it was that
that that thought that got planted in my
head that it can be learned and again a
lot more I focused on that after I I
realized that at Business School uh
Jeffrey feffer and one of my favorite
classes was managing um with power
politics and influence in organizations
and uh one of the things that I remember
from that class was this this this
phrase it was the last thing he said in
the class was that he used lots of
examples in his course about how in
organizations and governments and and
institutions you have people that are
really successful and uh and they they
really push the envelope of of
leadership they really push the envelope
sometimes of ethics and uh the question
is you know for you to realize where
that line is and one of the students you
know raised their hand and asked you
know that seems to be what you're
telling us that we have to push that
line and maybe walk over that line of
ethics and and and he said no what what
I'm telling you is um not telling you
what choices to make and I wrote down
exactly what he told me and I have it in
my files is that but if 10 years from
now you're in a junior position deep
inside on organization I don't want you
to wonder what happened to you and and
it was so insightful that quote to me
that and this happened to me by the way
I learned this lesson in the class and I
forgot it and it happened to me in my
first startup job and then it just came
back to me and hit me really hard and in
the next few jobs I actually applied
some of the principles in the book and I
worked so which I which I share some of
it with you um is the other experiences
like you know the entrepreneurship
classes or the the the the the various
projects and team activities that you
have um I met Bill Gage through this
process and um and I never forget at the
time Steve Jobs had left and started um
next corporation which was a new um
basically a hardware platform software
platform operating system and I think he
was trying to convince Bill to uh Port
all of his applications you know Ward
applications which is the real uh needed
ingredient for success of a new platform
having applications that run on this new
uh new computer and uh afterwards I was
huddling with Bill uh in one of the
auditoriums here and he said uh you know
I just left uh Steve and uh uh he's so
amazing and he's just so inspiring and I
just got to remember when I leave Steve
I got to come out and kind of hit myself
and pinch myself to get up to wake up
whether this is the right thing to do or
not and uh and uh it was really a
statement about charismatic Founders and
throughout my career actually hit this
point where I was so in love with the
founder and I was so passionate about
what what I was hearing and the lessons
I had uh and just admiring This
brilliant founder that I would have made
some bad choices stayed at a company too
long or a failing startup too long and
and again one of those moments helped me
to be decisive and leave and go to the
next startup that was hugely successful
uh and uh and and ultimately a brown bag
lunch year you know with all due respect
to the great bankers and Consultants uh
who who are in the room or you have
aspirations to be uh I was really not
meant to be one and uh but I got sight
thinking I could be one and uh and it
the sidetracking happened in business
school and the Savior happened in
business school so I got sidetracked in
business school then came back to
business school during a brownbag launch
and I'll talk about some of this later
that um really made me uh in my heart
really beat for the opportunity that I
was really after so both things happen
in this business school and again all
this collection of experiences and
portfolio that uh I developed is
something you were going to benefit from
and um my my one of my key messages is
that you have to to really be open to
that and and don't worry too much about
specialization or are you are you
learning exactly everything you wanted
to learn and just be open to surprises
and open to challenging yourself your
comfort zone and kind of flowing in
these next two
years so uh let me share with you some
of these experiences more specifically
and then relate it not only to my own
experience at business school but also
my career uh so uh coming to the GSP
experiences you know one of the things
again I really completely believe in is
that notion of following your instincts
and passion sometimes it sounds corny
but let me let me highlight it for you
uh you absolutely should not focus on
the money and again as all as mbas I
think we like money and we understand
money and we know how to calculate it
but that uh I'll give you two examples
both at GSP and later in my career the
the choice to go to Google which had to
do with absolutely not being focused on
money uh uh so the first part is the the
I Banking and Consulting Friendzy we're
all going to get into when it gets to
the jobs for the summer right everybody
wants to to figure out how to have this
great experience this prestig
prestigious job in one of the great
cities and then get this great bonus
that uh you can use to pay off your
loans and uh and then have to come back
for a couple of years and and work
really hard and uh make a lot more money
uh well I I joined that herd mentality
as well and uh and then luckily though I
got rejected on every first
round every first round of a management
consulting inter VI banking I was
rejected I was just not smart enough
analytical enough uh to to make the cut
and um but I was convinced this is what
I want to do and and what what happened
at business school which set me on the
wrong course for a quarter was uh these
two great classes actually by Jack
McDonald which uh what are they called
Investments and and and is he still
teaching he's he's an amazing professor
and and the class is this right of
passage you know you have to at the time
you know use up all your points to bit
to get into it and then there's this
whole Mystique around how you get in
there and then how you make it to the
next round and he does an incredible job
Warren Buffett us usually comes to a
school and talks to the whole university
and he has Warren Buffett just talking
to the class so it's just an amazingly
well done uh uh class and and and the
learning was was impressive you know I I
I I learned that you know perhaps I
could use my analytical and Engineering
skills to not only you know stay that
way and stay analytical and interested
in technology but also be in a field
where you can make a lot of money and be
be be that again focus on money wrong
wrong thing uh and I convinced myself I
got to join one of one of these U Banks
and Robert Stevens at the time was an
investment bank that I was trying to get
into uh to make the long story short uh
I actually got invited to a baseball
game uh with the director of the
department and I thought I've made it
and he was asking me all these weird
questions like you know tell me what was
wrong at HP and you know what did you do
about it and you know tell me what was
wrong with you know this company that
you hear about and what are you going to
do about it and I you know being a
positive marketing person at the time I
was here's what I would do here's what I
would fix this is what I did at HP and
uh after that baseball game I thought
the offer is going to be in the mail the
next day and he was like no no calls
from them no news so by the end of that
week I was so worried I called them and
he said sorry amid you're just too
positive for for this business and I was
like
what he said you know as investment
bankers or VCS perhaps you need to put
the companies down below and have them
crawl their way back up you can't be
like that positive that you know you did
this that I know you're not again uh
objective enough and like uh you know
you're too much of a you know bis person
now it's really interesting you know he
told me that and I should have realized
then that uh that's my career you know
bis Dev you know being able to sell
something so what happened is I actually
so this tells you something about my
selling skills I guess I convinced him
to offer me a job still on that
pH so he offers me the job
and
he offers me the job and I walk back to
to the the campus and there's this braw
bag lunch with this company called go
corporation which at the time was a PDA
company this is a precursor to all the
devices you have now you know all the
trios and blackberries you know this
stuff was started by this company called
go Corporation and uh one of our alumni
was presenting actually there and I went
into that to the room listening to this
presentation and this is what I mean by
instincts and yes sometimes it sounds
corny but it we are human beings and
it's real I sat there and I just my
emotions my my heart was saying this is
this is what I want to do this is not
the bank you know I kind of had this
sensation you know and you get carried
away by it the money you know was a
beautiful building in San Francisco
Robertson Stevens was this beautiful
Bank in Montgomery uh I'm sorry in
barcadera Center this sexy San Francisco
highrise and I was sitting in that lobby
waiting for my you know interview uh one
of those weeks prior and I just didn't
feel like it was me I just didn't feel I
belong there H and then yet in this
brown bag lunch I could not wait to
connect with this alumni to figure out
how I can get into the company so again
not only Stanford self-corrected for me
this openness to just be be there be
aware be be be present U but also the
alumni helped me because he eventually
got me into the company there's all
these other stories about how I show up
and the banker show up actually to take
us public and then they thought I had
accepted the offer Robertson Stevens and
they realized no I'm in this company now
so it's there all these hilarious like
uh comic
situations but uh uh that was the GSP
exp the other one again on the
non-financial part I like to emphasize
again don't focus on the money focus on
your passion is uh the Google story uh
and this also shows you a little bit of
the craziness of the bubble that we all
faced in the in the 90s uh the uh after
I met I'll tell you more about the the
background with with with Google but
after I met LGA and I was I got my offer
and negotiated over three weekends with
them uh then uh we uh I sat down and did
a spreadsheet and I had this offer to
stay at AOL and uh that's one thing we
learned by really well here how to do
the spreadsheets well and uh but you
know what the spreadsheets are right all
the it's all the assumptions that matter
and all my assumptions were were were
crazy so I made this assumptions about
you know AOL is going to double every
year I assumed AOL Time Warner that's
that's going to be very conservative
because my Netscape stock went from $15
to 100 split and went to 100 again and I
said I'm going to be conservative and
just assume that uh AOL is going to
double every year now for forget the law
of large number num right you learn that
here but the market valuation was
probably a couple of tens of billions at
the time and I still assumed it's going
to double every year and uh and that
shows you how bad the bubble was and
then with Google I said you know I don't
know you know it's a interesting
Founders and but very risky at best
maybe I'll be able to convince them to
sell this company to Yahoo for a couple
hundred million dollars and uh and I I
never forget this I have this
spreadsheet to this day financially the
two offers were a wash like you know
because I had a low very low s at at at
Google and just all this equity and uh
and so so financially it was a complete
wash and and I looked to my wife and
said you know what do you think you know
it was just no salary and and you know
no nice corporate Jets to fly around to
Dallas uh and but and he said you know
amid you're just a startup person you
your passion is to be in a smaller place
and you're not going to be happy uh you
know doing this bigger job in this very
complicated organization and purely
again based on that instinct and and
forgetting the financial calculation I
joined I join Google and uh and again it
just shows you these these decisions are
really not about all the math you can do
or all the all the assumptions a lot of
it is about your passion and your and
your gut feel and your
instincts uh the next big lesson I would
say is what I referred to earlier is
this portfolio of insights and wisdom uh
and uh not being worried about
specializing or kind of learning one
thing really well at the business school
uh it's really you know finding the
teachers that you find best uh that meet
what your learning criteria is and and
the subjects that really attract you to
it uh avoiding against subject matter
comfort zone uh I didn't realize when I
when I would come here um that uh I
would I would leave it the way I did I
thought I'm ready to be a CEO after I
left HP and I was kind of very confident
of that and I entered GSP thinking that
and I left it thinking that uh and the
the first company I got to go
Corporation I realized how unprepared I
was to be a CEO and I still am not
probably prepared to be a CEO uh so
again setting those kinds of objectives
for yourself and just being rigid about
it is is the wrong thing it's really
this portfolio of wisdom and learning
that really really matters um the
specifically let me give you um what
this did for me so I I started realizing
I have none of the kind of the classic
business training because I had I was an
engineer and I really wanted to learn
all that stuff and uh financial
accounting and cost accounting and learn
the process management stuff and and
again I was sorry bored to death about a
lot of those topics and what my real
passion was was organizations and
building building greatness building
companies and very quickly after I went
to some of these organizational behavior
classes and management principle classes
creativity classes I just got completely
attracted to that i' never actually made
it to some of the famous
entrepreneurship courses but which is
interesting I ended up being an
entrepreneur afterwards but but it was
that portfolio of learning that I
mentioned earlier feffer class on power
on politics all these leadership classes
um what I missed at go was this complete
lesson I thought you know just just
merits alone will do it you know that if
you do a great job you're going to
you're going to you're going to do it
and uh we were in a battle to win the
operating system um game uh against
Microsoft with these PDA devices ATO and
the biggest account at the time was
Compact and uh I tried to win that
account had this amazing uh um you know
ability to try to to win it and uh and I
lost it to Bill Gates that's the one
thing I can say he he he actually
basically convince compact that uh you
know with the the benefits they're going
to get with a Microsoft relationship the
operating system discounts they're going
to get and all these other things that
uh uh they bundled which is they're very
good at this they bundled all the
decisions to the operating system
decision and uh and uh and I I lost that
and even though I had worked so hard to
do this I was in a sales organization
and What mattered at the time was your
results and uh I had this colleague of
mine that had joined and um he was the
he was a hot new hire and very
experienced bu death person very
strategic and I didn't care about the
Dynamics of the politics and I didn't
care about the the the the leadership
view of that and I literally kind of
almost got demoted um I was kind of
headed that way and I I remembered F's
learning you know 10 years from now if
you end up in that position I want you
to know why it happened to you and I
remember that I remembered I was so
focused on just you know winning this
one deal and completely oblivious to all
the other things I got to do in an
organization to establish myself to
really be aware of uh what I'm great at
and where else I can contribute and um
and I decided to leave though I decided
to leave because it was kind of the the
losses were too much at that point I
couldn't recover from all
that and uh I applied to 3o which was
another hot company at the time in the
valley it was u a cons a gaming company
consumer gaming platform uh that was
going to compete with the Nintendos of
the world and PlayStations of the world
and the the idea was that there's only
one platform that's 3dio all the uh game
companies like Nintendo will license
this and develop games for it and we'll
make our all our money with royalties we
get from that reference design so it was
an ambitious goal it was an interesting
idea but uh but almost impossible to
pull off I mean it's just to imagine
these Giants of consumer electronics
would trust this little Silicon Valley
company with that platform and uh
reference design was just unimaginable
but we had this incredible founder trip
Hawkins I have a lot of respect for him
and uh he's he comes from that class of
Steve Jobs and the great Apple
entrepreneurs in the valley and um and
and and trip was so amazing he had these
strategy sessions and these company
meetings where you could sit there for 4
hours and and just eat it all up and
just like be mesmerized by what he
presents I think he has a GSP is or
maybe not I'm not sure yeah I think so
and uh he is so he's so impressive and
and we did a lot of things together in
that organization I learned my lessons
in power in politics and found my way to
work very closely I'm not talking about
you know brown noosing but finding my
way to to to establish myself not just
as an individual contributor but as a
leader in that organization and be
recognized as that and even survive a
massive layoff you know above me and
below me because I was recognized as
that leader even though around me things
were falling apart the lessons of fefer
really helped because people knew what
I'm capable of and I applied uh some of
those learnings some are very silly if
you're interested in we can cover in Q&A
but uh uh but what happened is I left
that one of these sessions it was after
we lost a ton of money and and and trip
to his credit was using his personal
money continually to fund a company uh
he was the CEO of Electronic Arts uh
founder of Electronic Arts so he's um
you know very successful before he
started 3o and uh I left that and I
remembered the gates conversation I
remembered Bill telling me you know I
have to leave Steve Jobs and kind of
slap myself to wake up sometimes and uh
and that was that's what I what I
remembered and again that moment at
Stanford completely unrelated to all the
classes uh guess what's the job it
landed me next it was Netscape when it
was just getting started so again I
think if I hadn't been here if I hadn't
been you know in tune with that learning
or in that in tune with that lesson I
would have maybe stayed there three more
years and you know missed the Netscape
rise and the whole internet Revolution
uh so again I really recommend you guys
being in tune with these things and and
and and and and this portfolio of
learning and insights in these classes
and in these
moments uh the third thing I like to
really share with you is the the first
steps do not have to be perfect you just
can't be that precise you know to decide
deci side you know this is exactly what
I'm going to do after business school
and this is exactly the right path I'm
going to be in uh because it's really
the learnings that matter it's it's
really being um it is being decisive it
is being uh building this portfolio of
learning but it's about building
relationships and credibility and and
kind of a track record I really believe
in that I mean I think some the some of
the problems with some of the jobs that
are so specialized is that you go into
this big organizations and you make a
lot of money potentially but um you kind
of don't interact with the world and
that's one of the things I like that
that uh about my job uh being a
partnership person and a sales executive
is that is that you you move through the
industries and you move between jobs and
and then you carry those relationships
with you be it the customer
relationships the partners or or the
employees you're with and that again
carries you forward so for example Bill
Campbell was a CEO of uh of go
Corporation the first startup and um he
was later CEO of Inuit and he's now an
adviser to our management team and our
board and at various points during my
decision Visions after I had left go
after I had turned my back I thought to
that company and had was a failure for
me that first start um he is now one of
my biggest fans and one of my dearest
friends and my coach and I I continually
get his advice on my career and the next
steps and be it business or be be be it
uh be it Career Development uh it's
really those portfolios and and and
those relationships and networks that
carry you um so uh so again the exact
job isn't doesn't even matter you know I
left went into the bis Dev job at go
then I decided the reason go failed
aside from my own failings was that the
product wasn't good so I want to be a
product person again so I went through a
3DO and I'm a terrible product manager
so I decided to become a product manager
and it was like miserable the first year
and then feffer thoughts woke me up and
I connected myself with the CEO of the
company and I became a Bev person even
though there was a VP bis Dev in the
company I was actually doing bis Dev and
again this is what I mean doesn't matter
some of these steps the specializations
doesn't matter it's the path and and the
and the learnings that that really
matter and ultimately I landed at
Netscape as an executive for BISD and
really kind of then finally felt this is
my career and this is what I'm really
good at that and then later led to
Google
relationships um at um at Google it's
really uh for me was an opportunity to
build a company and I think for all of
you who have that ambition I I highly
recommend that in that uh Netscape
wasn't quite that you know by the time I
joined it was 200 people they had a
executive team all built up and uh and I
think as business people we're actually
probably not great at the garage state
of a business you know maybe I'm wrong
some of you may find that appealing but
uh I wanted to be right outside the gar
right after the garage stage and uh and
Google just timing wise worked out that
way for me and um but again it happened
because of this network and this
relationships my previous boss at
Netscape was uh very successful after
Netscape and he ROM shiram he invested
in in Google as an angel round and he
introduced me to the the Google Founders
I thought for a business reason for me
to consider their techn technology for
for Netscape and AOL and um and again
this is where it all comes back together
again the the network of relationships
your instincts your portfolio of
learnings when I met the Google
Founders it was a lunch meeting and it
was a weird lunch meeting set up just to
get introduced to them I felt like I
looked in their eyes and I could just
see whatever they're going to be build
bu whatever they're going to be build is
going to be the next best thing I I I
just could sense that that that even if
you're going to build a mattress
together it didn't matter what the
company what the company was going to be
is that what they're going to do is
going to be fantastic and and again I I
was around technology enough that uh
that it uh that it worked now you heard
the interview story of course that had a
huge part in it uh but it was the again
the network that helped me the
references for example so at Netscape I
was working at the time for a very
successful executive Mike Homer and uh
Andy bealin who's a legendary uh uh
figure in the valley here who he was one
of the founders of sun Microsystems and
he sold several companies to Cisco and
uh was an angel investor in Google uh
Larry and ser were bright enough that
they surrounded themselves with a lot of
great advice and uh so how did they know
even my if my interview went well and
the dinner was good that they're going
to still trust me so they called up Andy
Beal Ste and others to do reference
checks on me so Andy calls me and again
realize I'm a Netscape pretty hot
company I'm a pretty successful
executive but it's still you know I'm
not in the top Echelon of the of the
industry and um even though I felt that
way
uh so Andy calls me on my phone and says
you know the Google guys have asked me
to to to talk to you and uh where do you
work I said Netscape who do you work for
Mike Homer he said thank you he hung up
I was like okay and then I quickly
realized what what it's all about again
it's that Network so he knew Mike like
the back of you know like like a true
friend so all he needed to do is talk to
Mike and not waste another half hour
interviewing me for a reference check so
it's uh it was really again this this
this this um Legacy of U of of
relationship ships of of being a solid
business person and and and even though
you leave these companies and you may
turn your back to some of those those
colleagues you do it with with um with
confidence but you do it in a nice way
uh for the right reasons and and that
portfolio of relationships come back to
help you every relationship I've
established at at at at Google started
with a bunch of these relationships uh
coming together so my first hire was
John Brad one of the most successful
Executives at Google and uh she was my
colleague at Netscape and um by the way
I'm very happy to see the numbers on on
women increasing at at at the Stanford
Business School a lot of My Success at
Google is is thanks to incredible Talent
of women in my organization and half of
my organization is women and it's about
4,000 people
so thank
you and uh and by the way I I've also
become very talented at figuring out how
to do the family life balance thing so I
can give advice on that and also how to
to manage very successful career
oriented women on my management team
where they need to take breaks like that
and come back and be stronger than any
man I've seen so congratulations on how
you do this I don't
know
uh let's see uh so building this
organization again was a lot of it was
thanks to the ability to to to to of
these relationships not only in terms of
the Partnerships and the business aspect
but also building the organization and
uh and that uh it's it's just something
I really recommend to all of you is that
I think building of organizations and if
you have this in you or you think you
have it in you you're not sure I wasn't
sure I learned it that at business
school that I can be a leader I I I
highly recommend that and that's a
that's a um that's just I think
ultimately when you build something and
there were classes here talking about
organizations building organizations to
last doesn't have to be a whole company
it can be a department it can be a small
uh nonprofit organization there is just
no greater to me uh uh sense of
accomplishment than than than than
building something incredible in the
world so uh I think I've talked probably
too long now is this time for Q&A maybe
uh let me just uh I think I I I weave
these comments throughout U my uh my my
talk but uh uh just just some uh nuggets
that I'd like to share with you uh which
I think we all share when we make it to
an incredible institution like Stanford
is that this this notion of you know uh
hiring greatness or or or getting
students that are so incredible and so
talented into in one place is is
absolutely a key ingredient of success
so at Google we never compromise this
and to this day all the execs review
every single uh every single hire every
single candidate and every single
package of hiring and it's painful it
really is painful to sit there Monday
afternoon and review you know tens and
tens of packages uh of of hires and and
and uh you know we hire a lot of people
every week uh and go through that but
it's absolutely true true that A's
higher A's and uh you know you've heard
about the Google maybe uh airport
airport test that that John dor and I
coined at Google it really is true and
and this you'll see this among your
classmates I mean these classes are so
intense these classes the learning is so
amazing is because of the the incredible
Talent that's in this room and when you
go out there and you're trying to hire
do not make compromis on that because it
doesn't matter how big your organization
is a single bad apple or a single bad
hire can ruin it uh Global Experience I
I just cannot say enough about that at
when I was rejected with all these
Investment Banking and and uh management
consulting jobs I went back and decided
you know I really want to do something
different so I went back to HP and found
an opportunity to work in Japan for a
summer and that learning alone just
learning how to show up in Japan and
live in a company dormatory actually and
and uh it was very tough experience but
helped me in every one of these startups
every one of these companies actually
had to deal with Japan uh now it's going
to be China probably as well as Japan
and you got to have that learning you
know I I basically got on a plane at
Google three years ago and went out to
establish all of our business operations
outside of United States and without
that kind of confidence and that
learning that I had I I was not going to
be successful so having Global
Experience Global Learning the diversity
in this class is is is is is impressive
to also provide a lot of that to you uh
putting yourself again out of that
comfort zone and uh talking to a
classmate which uh you may have a hard
time communicating with um or or dismiss
because they're not as good as uh you in
having uh strong voices in the class do
not underestimate that and that learning
is is very powerful and um and again I
would I would like to end this uh and
get to the Q&A by just saying you know
you're you're um you're all incredibly
talented and a lot of uh your time
should be really spent on on on kind of
putting that aside and really focusing
relaxing easing into this two years and
and do all the learning and build that
portfolio with uh with your classmates
and really trust your gut your passion
and and you'll find your path and you're
going to be very very successful hope to
run into you guys at Google or other
places and I'm glad to answer any
questions you may have thank
[Applause]
you um do you have can you talk a bit
more about your experience at 3o because
that seems like a really
transformational moment and how you
managed to rest start navigating the
company and uh get yeah the experience
are three the one the part I referred to
and again this stuff is not pushing the
ethics envelope which I was kind of uh
my classmate was worried about in the
power and politics class but I I was in
a I was in a role that was just not
right for me I was trying to do product
management I wasn't good at it I was in
an engineering driven company where
Engineers design the products not the
product managers so my boss um very very
successful lady McKenzie consultant was
like hammering me to develop the the
perfect product plan which I knew is
going to be useless uh because the
product was already designed by the
engineers and I was just in this no- win
situation that I didn't know really how
I'm going to get out of and again it
dawned on me I got to listen to to u to
the class learnings and and I just this
sounds really stupid but I'll just I'll
say it but I found my way just doing
even simple things where I would
normally go to like lunch a certain way
and I just made a point of going through
the kind of the executive row and just
walk through the executive row and and
just have the opportunity to run into
trip and just have a conversation about
what I'm doing or run into the Hugh
Martin who was the CEO of the company
and and what I'm doing or volunteering
myself to go on on a trip as a product
manager which I knew I'm not going to do
anything because the product was
designed there but go there to help and
and help with the situation the company
was facing and real and be be helpful
and be be do something else actually in
a company that was helpful not my
official job which is again sometimes
uncomfortable when you were in a small
company and a boss and you have a
specific job but but when you know
something something is wrong and and you
know the answer or you're trying to find
the answer just being open to to kind of
opening yourself up from the little
corner you're in and and not be heads
down um and connect yourself with other
people uh put yourself out there is
really what matters so um again some of
this stuff sounds sounds kind of corny
or sounds like you know I was trying to
pass through the executive role and
brown knows it wasn't really that it was
just trying to be more aware being more
connected and and then being available
to help and um and that big basically
what happened is the COO decided I'm so
good at the bizdev even though the head
of EP bizdev that he's going to help
have me help with a bunch of these
conversations and it wasn't easy and
because there was some conflicts and a
lot of great talent in the company and
it was hard my relationship with my boss
but ultimately uh it worked out for me
where where I I learned a ton more than
what what I would have done you know
sweating in my cubicle doing a 50 page
product plan which I knew was
useless you talked about your your your
passion for for startups and how being
in Netscape was you know was already a
big organization how do you feel now I
mean clearly it's not a startup
anymore good question I that's the one
thing to be honest with you I have a
struggle with and I'll share with you
something Eric told me our CEO uh I
really miss those days where everybody's
in one room or one building or you know
I talk to my entire staff in one kind of
conference room and now it's impossible
to do it they're all over the world
video conferences lots of trips and uh
so there's definitely an AS aspect of
that you miss and there's there are
people that get to the stage that they
just can't do it anymore and they have
to go to a to a smaller environment and
um I think Eric gave me the best advice
which is um uh you got to have a morning
session almost you know that period is
over so I can't pretend until you guys
Google is small and come there and it's
like a startup it's not true we do we do
things that are though very unique that
I think for companies in the valley or
companies in the world is that uh we
really believe in the power of small
teams and U keeping the the management
layers thin uh Eric literally counts
when we get to Promotions you know how
many directors do we have in a company
how many VPS do we have the ratios based
on the employees and to become a
director or a VP at Google is like is
just this incredible title and
accomplishment to uh uh to achieve the
um but keeping the team small keeping
the company Nimble keeping it Innovative
the 70210 model which you may have heard
about where 70% of our focus is on our
Core Business 20% is adjacent areas and
10% is is just wild any anything goes
you know ideas and experimentations that
we do I mean those kinds of things make
this culture really still vibrant so um
our goal is to keep Google this very
Nimble but large organization that's
growing and uh and we'll see how
successful we can be at it but uh uh but
it's there's obviously there's a
definite distinction where um um I maybe
I'm Inc correcting this but I think a
lot of people actually some some of the
early entrepreneurs left the company and
what I hear again is a lot of them again
enjoy maybe the time they're having off
and dabbling in New things but there's a
lot to be also said with a company of
the culture that Google still has where
there is that Nimble and small teams and
that focus on Innovation that U is still
very attractive where you can work on
something that is very small uh and and
make it a big business given the given
the resources that we
have when you arriv at Google you were
12 on the first business basically so
how did you introduce this business side
of things P
engineering good question I I think one
the credit goes to lar and Sergey on
this business savviness which is
again again this this is why Founders
are founders they're just incredible
Talent uh is that not only were they
really passionate about technology they
were absolutely passionate about
business also so it's was very very rare
for me to actually experience that where
a technical founder cares as much about
business as they do about technology but
one principle I always believe in and
believed in at the time was that uh when
it gets to partnership and revenue uh
Revenue will kind of illuminate the path
for you you know in a startup you just
don't and just like what I was talking
about business school where the first
step doesn't matter and a lot of us kind
of sweat to get that first step perfect
is that you got to get started you got
to you got to try sell sell and
establish Partnerships in every
direction you can and try to find a path
so some of it is a little bit chaotic
initially but you got to again know
where you're headed where where to give
up a path when you know it's a dead end
and where to you know put your resources
when you know uh this is the right one
so I really try everything I tried
selling it to Enterprises license search
to Yahoo on our competition um you know
start advertising tests on Google uh and
um uh you know consider custom projects
we'll do for companies just like decided
which one of these things makes sense
you know be just out there um be Global
one of the things I talk about is that
uh Google as a company uh was always
ahead of I'm sorry Google as a service
was always ahead of Google as a company
so from day one Google's usage outside
the US was accelerating uh to the point
today where we're completely a minority
the usage of Google in the United States
is a minority given uh all the
international usage of Google and uh but
our operations were so behind you know
we were like a very much a US entry
company so so you know get out there
establish business relationships outside
the United States and and start uh
hiring people outside the United States
so very you know strong recommendation
that I think companies especially
startups are are need need a business
executive that can have the confidence
but also the flexibility to try many
different things and and the revenue
flow will start Illuminating kind of the
business model I gave a talk in Tokyo uh
about a week and a half ago and we
talked about the um how one of the ways
to look at what's happening in the world
today is this um partial attentions that
we all have partial attentions now
there's no more Focus you know I hear
now in business school I guess people
have laptops with wireless access at
Google the staff meetings I wish I could
do a dunsbury cartoon on this one day
the St in the staff meetings I know a
googler here in audience that uh has uh
laptops uh everybody has laptops open
and it was so in to me still so
insulting but every time I argue with
laran Sur they say look it's the job of
the presenter to make the content
interesting otherwise I rather do my
email so so it's a brutal environment we
live in now and this partial attention
by the way from a business perspective
partial attention creates a scarcity you
know just like you know when something
scarce is more valuable and that's why
our model is so successful now you know
targeted advertising to capture you when
you are paying attention and be valuable
to you has a lot of value and that's
what the foundation of really our
business model is today so to answer
your question uh I uh I try to read as
much as I can but as um as quickly as I
can so what happens is I don't read the
full article anymore I'll you know open
to end I use the net a lot uh to search
Google news I love and
uh um but um it's um it's all out there
now which is amazing and and to to me
the power of searching and and uh news
is is very very very strong
now if you had a chance to come back to
Stanford Business school today from
where you are and have one course
designed specially for you how would you
choose to struct structure that course
what would you want in that course for
yourself what you're doing today and
your career from there on absolutely I
think uh it's it's it's very hard I mean
I actually do not envy Dean's position
and the faculty's position here because
I I do think it's so hard to do this and
and this is what I meant by the
portfolio you really pick up things in
every class you take and uh it could be
something very small like what John gner
said about uh leadership is uh something
that can be learned and that's the only
thing I really remember but I remember
you know was inspired in that class but
that's the one thing that stuck in my
head so I I think it's really that
exposure that matters so if the course
really exposes you um you know actually
let me before before I go further there
was a there was another class I forget
the name of it was managing uh a
management course and uh and it was a
very light course and the professor was
a wonderful Professor here I forget his
name he um he was an old Oldtimer and uh
and uh he was actually very impressive
he was this very he was a older
Professor but he had these amazing
biceps very fit you remember
him what was the
name I'm not sure
Dean Dean Josh is
a Dean Josh is a young man no no he was
he was impressive actually but the
course was so light I mean in terms of
like I just coasted through it but uh
but it was like the basics of everything
it was like uh you know doing Financial
teachings of what an irr is and you know
and my investing backing classmates
could probably slice and dice it in 10
million ways in more sophisticated
classes than I was able to but it was
just teaching me the basics of an exp
exposing me and he even did a silly case
study on on you know let's say if you
have you come to your work and you have
these priorities between like um your
your management team is about to quit or
someone is about to quit they want to
talk to you and you have the customers
calling you know you know how do you how
do you choose between all these
priorities and it was something like
that but again my my point is I think
it's very hard to do this I think the
more you're exposed to the variety of
organizational and Leadership uh
questions either through the case
studies or through um the variety of
courses you take is the key I don't I
don't think it's possible to do one
course that we captures it all so I
don't envy the position I think it's
very hard given the demand that your
family career already have or had why
did you decide to
become
good good question I I you know one of
the things that actually I think is
lacking from my when I look at my my
accomplishments on bio is uh I've been
terrible at just doing extra stuff and
I'm again thanks to Karen who accepted
me because compared to I think what you
guys have to go through now and the
kinds of things you have to go through
or the my children probably have to go
through to you know be not just the
perfect violinist but also been on an
Asian you know shipping service and you
know caught whales
and hopefully not to kill to to save but
but
like but but uh it I I just that that
part of my I was so focused on two
things the family two kids um you know
my son was born the the month I joined
Google and uh and then and then these
startups and my career that I literally
just refus to do anything any boards any
philanthropic stuff and uh and again my
my wife thankfully did did a lot more of
that and and today this is one of my
biggest challenges in fact the day I
came to the advisory I was it was
miserable I mean I felt really
embarrassed because I came in late and
had to go out take calls and but I got
to become better at that I I have to be
able to because I I learn a lot through
sessions like this I learn a lot through
a advisory committee and hearing the
challenges of the business school and
changing the curriculum building the new
building uh I'm not supposed to say that
I know because it's GNA be nice you can
come back and visit
it and uh but it's uh uh I think it's
important to do that it really is and
for those of you who can can manage that
you know all the power to you I I just
needed to kind of put the energy all
behind the career and and the and the
family and I guess the message is also
is you can be successful I mean you
don't have to do everything at the same
time just given the demands on our
careers and our lives you just it it is
um um it is doing what's important to
you and what really matters and
eventually you'll be able to come back
and and and do more that's one of the
advice I'm getting today which is one of
the other things I'm doing today this
afternoon is how do how can I be more
helpful to the school um both from uh my
involvement financially other ways I
could help and uh the first thing you
want to do is jump and do something like
you know uh I I thankfully I'm in a
position that you know I I can write a
check if I want to I can just do this
but I but I felt like you know I need to
know I need to know more I need to kind
of not be rushed to do this and really
understand um how to uh how to do it and
again my advice is just get started you
know you know I you know I fall in this
pattern sometimes where I have to figure
out the perfect Next Step but uh it's
really just getting started and I think
uh maybe to end on this note uh you guys
have definitely picked the right place
to start so uh the rest is up to you
thank you
than